колеги
Схаменіться Ну що ви робите ну зараз до
нас звернулися посли Великої сімки Да
може подобатись не подобатись Але ж ми
їх просимо б за гроші ми ж до них Ідемо
І кажемо Сполучені Штати Америки дайте
нам грошей Канада дайте нам грошей
Великобританія Франція Японія дайте нам
грошей а далі Німеччина дайте нам грошей
а далі а далі вони звертаються до нас
позавчора всі посли це спільна позиція
говорять не призначайте нових членів
рахункової палати до прийняття нового
Закону тому що вони хочуть знати що їхні
гроші порахують вони відповідають перед
платником податків з США з Франції з
Німеччини щоб нам віддати їхні кошти
щоби ми тут відбудовувалися збереглися А
ми що говоримо нам наплівать